welcome to this 170th commencement
ceremony of hillsdale college
thank you for coming
let us remember to be grateful for the
blessings of the lord upon this college
which have been abundant
the ceremony is on the occasion of the
graduation of the seniors
but it's not just about them
it took everybody here
to produce this ceremony take the
faculty
and the work they have done to lead us
through the things we need to know
because of what we are
they live with the students they laugh
with them
they eat with them they cry with them
the parents are important
this room is full of parents
swelled with pride
they spend a third of their lives or
more
taking care of these young people
and what they give to their children is
everything they've got
they're friends of the college here
they support the college
everybody in this room
and everybody watching is part of the
achievement that we're here to celebrate
today
as a group and individually these
seniors are the best we ever had and i
went back in my notes from last year and
verified that i said that last year too
and it was true both years
and i expect it will be true next year
you get a year to be top of the heap
but you are awesome people and you will
be greatly missed here
except you are not leaving after all
you're going to live the life
that you have prepared yourself to live
and you're going to live it in contact
with this college which is a partnership
that includes you
you seniors new graduates
you're at a pinnacle
of sorts
that's one metaphor pinnacle another how
about a crossroads
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go one direction or another
and there's an old blues
idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally
because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
you aim up or down
and so you know you're called upon to
to take the lessons that you've been
taught in a university like this that
that teaches you to abide by the eternal
verities to sacrifice your own narrow
pretensions in the highest sense to
something that's truly better anything
you pursue that isn't that is
insufficient
you're a particularized creature as a
son of god or a daughter of god let's
say you have something to bring into the
world that no one else can bring in
and so if you fail in that duty then you
deprive the world of that
there's no shortage of suffering in life
and no one thinks their own suffering
isn't real
and maybe there's a possibility that
there's some aim that's so high that the
attempt alone to move in that direction
is of sufficient value to
act as a panacea for the suffering and
so you could say at the end of your life
oh my god that was so hard
it was worth it
and so that's the choice you make at the
crossroads
if you have any sense
now at our freshman convocation dr aaron
told us to get your boots on
we have to have this inherent desire to
learn and to expand our knowledge
hillstone's given that to us here at
hillsdale
we are meant to be together as a family
and more importantly
we are meant to achieve self-government
together
and along the way
you'll set down a path
and live an example for others to follow
for the same end
in other words
keep your boots hot
i was going to speak more extensively
but dr jordan peterson covered most of
the topics i had planned to talk about
actually i am here in my capacity my
proud capacity as chairman of the board
of trustees of hillsdale college and i'm
representing the board when i first of
all thank the graduates for all they
have brought to this campus over the
last several years you have not only
received a world-class education you've
learned what it takes to be a a good and
effective citizen you spend time
thinking about and talking about
the good and the true and the beautiful
all that is inside you now and it's just
up to you to get out there and and shine
a light on the world from all of us here
again congratulations to the 170th
graduating class of hillsdale college
[Applause]
[Music]
you